see Magnus Carlsen arag I see fighting
for a comeback he cannot lose this game
but the bar is over to magnus's side
after 20 moves what are we looking at
yeah it looks on the face of things
quite a standard position but I think
um this firstly came from a night of
Sicilian or at least it looks that way
um but secondly
a few small factors firstly the Queens
are about to come off the board as a
patsy
it's about the Bishops as well white
Bishop stuck staring at its own pawns
it's what we call a bad Bishop when it's
blocked in Blacks Bishop very very
strong and despite the fact Black's King
is in the center it's holding the fort
the center blocked means it's very safe
white has no plan black has an easy plan
just kick away this Knight and uh oh
this is an ugly move to have to play for
aragaisy maybe it's the best one uh or
maybe it's what he had to do moves The
Rook across but now he's just staring
behind a pawn Rooks hate this right and
uh the whole idea is that now after the
pawn push at least the Knight has an
escape Square uh it doesn't really want
to go to the edge of the wood so it
Retreats and maybe on a good day you can
start jumping out
to fresher pastures but it's still a bit
sad can you get greedy
that's so greedy I know I don't know
normally I would never ever think about
taking that pawn but uh the whole kind
of premise is that if you try to trap it
I'm just going to go well the joke's on
you my friend because I'm going to
capture it yeah I'll say the other dude
do you require like this like stick your
finger in the socket
I kind of do Magnus did get greedy and I
think he's justified in doing so we
should mention uh that previous
variation we just showed it does work
Black's Bishop isn't trapped but nine
times out of ten you don't really want
to go and grab a pawn like that one
because you will get your piece trapped
Behind Enemy Lines uh so this time it
didn't quite work for aragaisy but what
do you think of his last move uh Ivanka
pushing this Pawn forward is he just
trying to confuse Magnus
yeah I think so I mean you've got to
roll the dice otherwise magnus's forces
are just simply overrunning his own
so I mean get active I mean the black
king is potentially a little bit unsafe
yep so if
it doesn't feel great it's backing in
the center necessarily there was only
one move that I think blacks should
never have played and that was actually
to push the B Pawn forward
then you voluntarily trap your own
Bishops don't do that you might not lose
your Bishop here but it definitely
wouldn't participate in the rest of the
game
so Magnus found a really nice solution
another one I wouldn't have chosen
White's Pawn push was two squares so you
can actually legally capture on passant
you can take it as if it just moved one
square but this would have only allowed
the White Knight back into the game in
some of the previous uh previous
tournaments yeah it's just that um if
you sometimes you know want to win with
white very
um
I mean very badly then
I mean
such such disasters may happen
and also of course the second game was
kind of crucial because
um I wasn't better in that game but um
I I think I want basically because of I
was I mean I'm kind of more used to
playing on on a lot of time and and I'm
I think I'm just queer so that prepares
in the end
yeah very impressive though and we are
following uh game three Arjun aragaisy
against Magnus Carlsen you will face the
winner of this match and if Magnus wins
this game uh his position
um
looks very nice I mean he's clearing
comment and also I mean he because he's
reading right I won't have to have so
um if I if I'm not mistaken so um yeah
it's like um 1990 99 percent Agnus for
sure tomorrow yeah I mean of course uh
I mean if I if I if I play
um good chess in this in this
tournaments then most likely I will face
Magnus I don't think like no swear uh BS
Mercy I think I think the history
doesn't doesn't matter at all so be
honest and and to play and the best as I
can yeah it's going to be a very cool
match we wish you best of luck tomorrow
young Christophe it looks that way or do
you think you haven't got any saving
chances here for Arjun I mean just
during that interview with the ancest of
Duda I mean we just saw magnus's
position just getting better and better
and now he has a rook on the second row
I mean that Rook just cannot be captured
he has a beautiful night on F6 targeting
a pawn I just I don't see anything no
it's it's essentially a good night
versus bad Bishop scenario White's still
been left with that terrible Bishop just
it looks like a big Pawn just defending
everything and uh yeah as you say the
final
I mean that Rook it's never ever going
anywhere it's just a thorn in white side
you can never take it because black will
just replace it with a pawn and promote
and uh if the Queens disappear I mean if
they don't first of all you just take
this Pawn if they do disappear
um
this is just coming you can never ever
take this Rook remember because black
makes a new Queen
okay he's really trying to park the bus
now again here we go see just putting
his Rook on the Square but
your plan Ivanka maybe again move the
queen across or worse comes to worse if
you want to keep things simple reroute
this Knight around
to a slightly more active Square yeah
and goes for your options yeah he goes
for my option and I think the best thing
to do is actually trade off Queens
because if you allow the queen to grow
Pawn grabbing it's not going to be good
news it's not good news anyway
yeah don't see how you stop this Pawn
really cement this Rook cemento as Peter
lecker would say and I think we might
see this on the board
um the problem is you can't take this
Rook because uh these uh two pawns
they'll probably just become two queens
Arjun he's fighting his till his last
breath but I think we're going to see
the black pawn step forward okay he
doesn't go for it yet that's not running
away never let our drink get active this
game never let Arjun get active still
strategically very complicated lots of
pieces on the board earlier your idea
now cement that Rook
that black Rook is just numbness
oh and you can see the pain on ericice's
face
oh
yes laughing about that road but
actually yeah it's difficult to see when
a player knows they're about to go down
to defeat it's inevitable now yes
blackbrook too strong and the King does
move over
the night is coming just leave that Rook
where it is yeah and here you go
our Magnus is such a killer he's so
ruthless in these type of positions he's
not going to let the slip at all and now
the pawn on e4 is gonna fall and with it
the game yeah
devastated I've been playing so good in
the whole tournament he ended up above
Magnus Carls and then the preliminaries
in fourth place
but he's just such a tough not to crack
in a match yeah and again Audrey trying
to curl up into a ball just putting his
pieces on their last safe squares
but white is almost in zuk Swang white
can barely move I'm expecting Magnus to
do something with his King now I don't
think he'd want to rush and trade off
Rooks I don't think you want to rush and
move the Black Knight away because then
White's Rook will gobble up the Deep one
so giving up a pawn I was wondering
about this anything to get the king into
the game yeah and
okay King is Coming he's coming and it's
going to go all the way to the third row
nothing to do
Arjun is completely paralyzed
you still can't take that black Rook
because black will take back and make a
new Queen
is this where you just don't want to
move any pieces every move kind of
worsens your position this is where
you'd like to have like magical moves
but you'd like to kind of magically
transport your king that would be a cool
chest Brian it's just one stirring every
game you can just place a piece anywhere
yeah I agree but then you've got me no
you don't but then you have like this
new game coming any chance yeah that's
true where you're gonna have the magical
ideas yeah yeah you can use the magic
and spells yeah you can freeze your
opponent from moving once again this is
what you would like to do this is what
era Geiser would like freeze Magnus yeah
have like five moves
the problem is even if you can sit still
and not commit anything with white
Black's got a clear plan Black's King is
coming towards the white Rook it's one
square away now from attacking that
white Rook and that will tip the
defenses over the edge
simply nothing to do if you push the
white pawns the black king will happily
just take a time out and go and take
them back first and then the black king
will come in
and it's nice to see a tweet like that
from Amrit Patek who says you know so
sad but super proud of our gem so uh
yeah he is a star in the making and this
is just another lesson to be learned
we've seen Arjuna come back stronger
he's going to do it again yeah yeah oh
absolutely only 19 years old
we started with three Indians in The
Knockout stage weedit is already knocked
out by Duda aragaisy about to be knocked
out can gukesh make it to the
semi-finals to be the only Indian to do
so
and Magnus this is just putting the boot
in now he's actually ignoring White's
pawns white could even make a new Queen
but he's going for checkmate and uh yeah
the problem is the white king is
completely stuck
you can give up the white Rook go with
some pawns should we show the Checkmate
on the board on the board I think we
might see a resignation any moment but
okay he's going to try and make a new
Queen Magnus is going to take this rook
and he's going to trap the white King by
bringing his Rook across white can make
a new Queen but too slow the king is
trapped and uh we'll see okay similar to
this at least happen on the board right
now
uh this King
nowhere to go and we see Magnus play
that move in the current position he is
threatening the killer blow pushing the
pawn forward checkmate
and there we go I have a result the
quarterfinal match is over Magnus
Carlsen wins it in three games Arjun
aragaisy he looks devastated but he put
up a good fight he almost won the first
game but Magnus fought back to draw that
game and winning two games in a row
Magnus Carlsen is ready for the
semi-finals